la photographie la vidéo complètement
bouleversé notre société finalement on
était capable de figer ou de cas vu dans
son entièreté un moment précis
évidemment ça l'a considérablement
enrichi une mémoire collective et des
images qui ont transcendé les
générations puis ont marqué notre
imaginaire
il ya des moments historiques qu'on sait
pas vraiment la date où les détails mais
on est capable d'y associer une image
bien précises par contre l'image et pas
seulement été un témoin passif que notre
histoire m'a grandement contribué à son
évolution
je pense entre autres à la photo une
jeune vietnamienne qui courent de son
village après avoir été brûlée au napalm
cette photo aurait été prise en main par
nick ut et elle a fait la première du
time magazine en 1972
soudainement la guerre du vietnam était
une gare anonymes qui se passait à des
kilomètres de chez nous mais à la main
le visage elle avait des souffrances ces
footeux leur complètement bouleversé
l'issue de la gardienne am legend on m'a
dit qu'ils ont commencé à manifester à
se révolter que les dirigeants
politiques ont pesé dans le choix que
d'opter pour une nouvelle stratégie
c'est donc dire que le pouvoir l'image a
le pouvoir de changer les choses
à l'apparition de la photographie les
appareils photos étaient des zones homme
machine qui était difficile à manoeuvrer
qui était très lourde et coûtait très
cher donc en fait c'est souvent les gens
qui avaient les moyens financiers d
opérer piste est vraiment un petit
groupe de personnes tranquillement tout
au long du siècle on a vu l'amélioration
les appareils photo sont devenus plus
compact plus facile à opérer
on a vu l'apparition dans les années 50
70 fermé polaroïd ont envoyé notre photo
directement ensuite dans les années 1970
les appareils reflex
argentique finalement les années 80 et
le fameux petit appareil contact compact
qui pour moi représente beaucoup de
souvenirs parce que c'est le premier
appareil photo comme à faire les fameux
appareil jetable où on allait en voyage
en train et 6 puis on revenait on
apprend des deux semaines pour avoir nos
photos quelques mois un résultat un peu
douteux mais on est tellement contents
d'avoir puis dans les années 90 en fait
le numérique a fait son apparition au
début c'était une technologie qui était
très très cher mais les rendements
devenu accessible aujourd'hui parce que
tout le monde a des bons appareils
photos ils sont capables de faire la
bonne photo la vidéo si vous un peu la
même évolution
donc on avait des gros appareils qui
étaient difficiles à repérer qui peu à
peu on a eu l'amélioration de la qualité
l'image du son et puis c'est un peu la
même chose ici pour les systèmes de
montage moi je me rappelle avoir mes
premiers montages avec deux vhs
aujourd'hui des systèmes sont vraiment
rapides qui se parent très facilement en
fait aujourd'hui on peut dire que
presque tout le monde est capable de
filmer ou prendre les photos parce que
presque tout le monde sait ça cette
option le sociocide l'air c'est donc
dire que le pouvoir en fait de changer
les choses qui appartenait un petit
groupe de personnes est maintenant dans
les mains tout le monde c'est un pouvoir
qui nous permet en fait d'émouvoir les
gens d'aller toucher leur sensibilité
puis de leur ouvrir les yeux à une
nouvelle réalité qu'on dit qu'une image
vaut mille mots
c'est vrai en 2008 j'étais en bolivie
j'ai voyagé avec une amie en bolivie on
a été on est rentré dans les mines de
potosi qu'on allait ramener des images
comme celles ci sur la situation des
mineurs en bolivie qu'on est revenu de
voyage on a montré ses photos là nos
amis à nos collègues à nos professeurs
puis fallait suscité beaucoup de
curiosité et d'intérêt de débats de
discussions parce que peu de gens qui
connaissaient cette situation là
évidemment non pas la prétention d'avoir
changé les choses mais on a au moins
éveillé la conscience de certaines
personnes je pense que l'éveil de la
conscience c'est effectivement la
première étape pour opel pour opérer un
changement dans la société
cette auto léger les prix à new york il
ya deux ans ces images qui parlent
d'elle-même
celle ci j'avais plus au maroc
l'année suivante et encore une fois
c'est une image qui parle d'elle-même
donc le paradoxe quand la dame qui vous
allez et la jeune fille qui était en
bikini
j'ai mis ces photos là sur mon site
internet sur ma page facebook qui salait
encore une fois créer des débats
intéressants
des discussions constructives et vit
dans un monde où on a beaucoup d'image
on est un peu sur saturé d'imagés on a
toujours l'impression que ça la moindre
importance
de nos jours pourtant il ya toujours des
images qui reviennent qui deviennent
virale donc l'impact est toujours là et
on a une responsabilité face à cet
impact
de nos jours on a un peu tout et
n'importe quoi sur internet sans trop y
réfléchir
alors qu'on peut vraiment avoir un
impact important évidemment sinon très
puissante mais c'est aussi un homme très
dangereuses on peut autant faire de bien
que de mal
il n'allait pas fait je suis allé en
afrique donc je suis parti tout seul en
tanzanie
sac au dos les premières réactions que
j'ai eu quand j'ai annoncé mon voyage
aux gens autour de moi c'était plutôt de
la crainte il ya toujours quelqu'un qui
connaît quelqu'un qui est arrivé quelque
chose en afrique d'un peu tragique le
continent est vu comme un pays né qui
est un peu diaboliser et comment je suis
arrivé là bas j'ai vu totalement autre
chose j'ai vu la chaleur humaine j'ai vu
des gens ingénieux j'ai vu des gens
simples et quand je suis revenu je me
suis dit je me suis donné comme mission
de présenter ce côté-là de l'afrique
donc c'est beaucoup telle des gens
heureux positif et je me suis demandé
mais la mission de donner cette image là
aux gens on organise une soirée avec
quelques amis dont le présenter les et
les images sur écran géant
j'avais vraiment réussi ma mission à la
fin parce que une cire conflit au
pinceau qui sont nos morts puis se sont
dits qu'ils m'ont dit eh ouais bon c'est
vrai un peu c'était comme ce sens n'a
vraiment envie d'y aller donc j'ai la
chance d'en voyager beaucoup j'ai voyagé
dans tous les continents et je rends mon
tour des photos des photos avec des
histoires des photos de gens ce moment
moi je suis passionné par le portrait et
je me rendais quand je raconte une
histoire puis que j'ai l'image en
arrière puis je peux donner la photo de
la personne les gens ils sont sensibles
ça leur permettre de même perspective
sur leur propre réalité
puis de regarder un peu les choses
différemment donc c'est tous des photos
que j'ai pris au cours de mes derniers
voyages évidemment quand les
photographes ou vidéastes amateurs on a
souvent l'impression
qu'est-ce qu'on fait ça va
quelques personnes dans notre entourage
notre famille nos amis nos collègues
mais que ça a un rapport vraiment plus
loin pourtant la vidéo la photographie
favorise rapidement avec toutes les clés
les canaux qu'on est maintenant avec
internet
ça peut facilement se rendre à leur goût
du monde en quelques secondes en 2011
j'ai commencé ma maîtrise à hec montréal
en affaires internationales et j'ai
décidé de faire mon projet sur le
développement des coopératives dans les
pays en développement pour favoriser
l'inclusion sociale dont le faire
quelque chose d'un peu original qu'un
peu différent de d'un simple projet j'ai
décidé de réaliser un documentaire
j'avais jamais réalisé le documentaire
de ma vie j'avais même jamais toujours
appareil photo donc si nous partions
nouvelle et non je suis parti a remis de
ma caméra et j'ai fait un
un documentaire en équipe d'accueil sur
un groupe de femmes on en reste du
brésil qui font de l'artisanat j'ai
passé un mois avec ces dames l'a1 peut
capter leur moment puis c'est marrant
parce que quand je suis arrivé j'avais
je suis arrivé un peu comme toute
personne qui arrive
fraîchement sorti la maîtrise en disant
je veux changer les choses vont leur
apprendre plein de choses sinon j'ai
vite réalisé que elles m'ont appris
beaucoup plus que je leur ai appris la
première journée que j'ai travaillé avec
elle sur la place j'ai perdu
connaissance parce qu'il faisait
tellement chaud il travaille tellement
fort si moi j'avais pas d'énergie puis
elle est son continuel vendre en même
temps que quelques produits leurs
produits c'est vraiment impressionnant à
voir donc j'ai pas fait vraiment
vraiment à capter de chacun leurs
éléments leur moment leur leurs pensées
puis comment ils sont commencé à
s'organiser dans une coopérative
j'ai remis mon projet final et ça sent
peut terminer je pensais que le projet
malheureusement mes amis les collègues
l'auraient vu mais sans plus un an plus
tard on a refusé de le présenter au
festival international des nations unies
parce que c'était l'année des
coopératives sans vraiment aucune
attente je vais présenter qui contre
toute attente et j'ai gagné
donc je suis allé le présenter à new
york donc c'est assez impressionnant de
se dire que l'histoire d'un groupe de
femmes isolées
on en reste brésil sur un dans un petit
lieu il faut y aller on dit qu'en bateau
s'est rendu jusqu'aux nations unies et à
new york et en fait elle a eu des
répercussions pour moi évidemment notre
vie a changé mais la loire aussi obtenu
une subvention qu'elles ont pu continuer
à faire leur projet un organisme à but
non lucratif du brésil
donc comment cette histoire là ça a été
vraiment que du positif
puis on a pu le transmettre qu'on en a
un souvenir à travers la vidéo je veux
pas terminer ma présentation sans vous
présenter ce fameux qui ont
définitivement changé le cours de m
nos jeunes ont bien sûr sa défense
envisage la pâte pour renommer mal il
faut commencer par des crochets courts
coïncidence le nommer haïm et a prédit
pas décroché courtage et des hommes
appelés dit vous êtes étudiant français
prochaine nous nommer rémy et après il
faut décrocher pour les jeunes italiens
le mont mesly penderie ici l'eau
avantage dans ce conte d'automne ou
royaume a prêté main forte lemagit en
face au projet
l'année dernière que j'ai fait mon thème
c'est comme ça que je finissais ma
présentation
mais cette année j'ai vécu quelque chose
qui mérite vraiment à peine d'être
partagé puis juste renforcé mes propres
convictions par rapport au pouvoir de
l'image en octobre dernier un meilleur
ami a été poignardé dans le dos à la
sortie d'abord parce qu'il est
homosexuel
son attaque le laissé paraplégique donc
il marchera plus jamais de sa vie faite
en chaise roulante pour le restant de
ses jours
et quand vous vous arrive quelque chose
comme ça il ya beaucoup
d'incompréhension autour il ya beaucoup
de tristesse de tristesse de rage de
frustration je me suis rendu à son
chevet à l'hôpital puis j'ai trouvé
quelqu'un qui avait une force un courage
vraiment incroyable et encore sur son
lit d'hôpital il ya décidé que s'il
avait perdu ses jambes ça allait servir
une cause beaucoup plus grande que lui
donc il voulait lutter contre
l'homophobie est encore aux soins
intensifs il ya commencé à penser à son
message il son message était simple
c'est donc bien au frais n'ayez pas peur
et le bo de dons bien fait et que ça
englobe deux choses dont be afraid
d'être vous-même dans le bus et fred de
l'homosexualité et moi c'est vrai que
c'est un super leur campagne j'ai alors
vu un peu de m d'ajouter mon grain de
sel à fait donc quand je suis revenu
chez moi montréal
j'ai fait une toile avec un ami on a
fait une toile et qui était donc bien
faire et on s'est mis à prendre des
photos évidemment la première photo fait
la mienne et je me suis mis à prendre
des photos de mes amis en ramassant des
phrases positive sur soi-même contre ou
sur l'homophobie et on s'est créé une
page facebook un peu pour pour mettre
les photos et rapidement logement a pris
de l'ampleur
on s'est mis à le savoir des photos de
ton ami d'argentine
on a aussi des photos de l'australie on
a aussi des photos d'angleterre de
france
ils ont été de plus en plus créatifs
donc en fait leur propre toile ont
décidé que j'allais faire leur propre
truc et à envoyer leurs propres messages
parce qu'il a envie de faire partie de
mouvements le nous mêmes on a pris des
photos des images fortes
deux groupes de personnes téléphone on a
tendance à penser que ce débat défendant
des gens qui vont être les plus portés à
partir à ce genre de campagne on a pris
des gens de toutes les générations et on
est rendu à plus de jeux pense 300
photos maintenant et on a ramassé une
communauté près de cinq mille 5000
personnes autour de cette cause là et
les gens sont toujours touchés par
l'image partagent les images partage le
message qu'on a envie de passer
aujourd'hui scott
ça fait six mois de son attaque film les
personnes que j'admire le plus au monde
c'est une des personnes les plus
positives que je connaisse et la
campagne a pris de l'ampleur
c'est pour lui une force aussi dans sa
propre mutation quelque chose en quoi
croire aujourd'hui donne des conférences
il va parler aux gens on aurait ça crée
des événements on ouvre le dialogue en
présente des photos
et tu sais pas si en fait d'un simple
projet photo mec a pris de l'ampleur qui
aujourd'hui est géré par pour moi en
scott
donc je pense que cet événement lui qui
est à la base tournait vraiment quelque
chose de positif
donc je pense que c'est vrai qu'on peut
faire quelque chose de positif avec
l'image ce pouvoir là nous appartient il
ya tous taxés ou presque donc il faut
l'utiliser pour assurer un meilleur non
merci